le nitrite il y a nitrite de sodium dans
les charcuteries qu'on consomme en
France il y a le nitrate de potassium
c'est deux deux additifs de synthèse ça
n'a rien à voir je connais le nitrate de
sodium alors le nitrate vous vous le
connaissez parce que vous souvenez par
exemple Beyrouth il y a 2 ans c'est du
nitrate d'ammonium qu'avait explosé sur
le port de Beyrouth AZF c'était du
nitrate d'ammonium c'est pas ça qu'on
met dans la charcuterie nous ce qu'on
met dans la charcuterie dans certains
jambons c'est du nitrate de potassium
qui également c'est une substance
chimique qui est à l'origine était
utilisée pour fabriquer tout simplement
de la poudre à canon comme ça qu'on a
commencé à utiliser d'une trappe de
potassium du nitrite et l'autre c'est du
nitrite de sodium je vous en ai apporté
une petite bouteille un petit ça c'est
une nitrite de sodium
Cyril ça ça peut déboucher un chiotte
plus que ça
avec ça
on tue 50 personnes
j'ai 200 g 200 g
on peut commencer par ce côté-là
[Rires]
qui a été on a vu Richard Ramos le
député j'ai été auditionné comme ça fait
des années que je travaille sur la
question et je leur ai apporté une
petite capsule et j'ai dit au député à
l'Assemblée je leur ai dit là je vous ai
apporté 4 g de nitrate 4 g de nitrite de
sodium si j'avale ça dans une demi-heure
je suis au sol d'abord je vais commencer
à être tout bleu ça s'appelle c'est une
cyanose et dans une heure je suis mort
après c'est tout c'est redoutable c'est
incroyable ce que vous dites mais à quoi
on s'en sert pourquoi alors ça ça à
l'origine c'est pour travailler la tôle
c'est un produit alors en plus ça coûte
rien à fabriquer le nitrite de sodium
c'est
quelques quelques euros de fabrication
pour un pied pour pour un sac de 5 kg
alors le nitrite de sodium à l'origine
c'était utilisé pour fabriquer des
pigments pour fabriquer de des produits
chimiques très utilisé par l'industrie
chimique surtout pour travailler la tôle
ça réagit avec le métal et jusqu'en 1924
c'était personne n'avait une idée
d'utiliser ça dans la charcuterie 1924
il y a des crapules américaines du de en
fait de la mafia
dans l'Illinois dans à Chicago qu'on
réussit à convaincre des des
personnalités plus ou moins corrompues
de mettre du nitrite de sodium dans la
charcuterie la France a dit tout le
temps il en est pas question en 1934 je
vais pas faire un cours d'histoire là
mais c'est ça que je raconte dans le
bouquin
1934 Adolf Hitler arrive au pouvoir et
il autorise le nitrite de sodium dans la
charcuterie c'est le premier en Europe
qui autorise ça officiellement ce que je
raconte dans le livre au début les
charcutiers Français disent regardez de
l'autre côté de la frontière ils
utilisent du nitrite de sodium c'est
vachement avantageuse ça donne une belle
couleur très rapidement c'est un
conservateur pour eux qui donne le
produit une une couleur qui va rester
longtemps au longtemps sous les étalages
avec le bel aspect tout appétissant tout
frais tout sexy j'ai envie de dire même
cette tranche de jambon est toute belle
et toute rose c'est pas du tout naturel
et bien les autorités françaises ont
demandé à des experts et les experts je
commence le bouquin avec ça les experts
ont dit mais il en est pas question
c'est un poison c'est sur la liste
officielle des poisons oh c'est interdit
on en met pas dans la bouffe on n'en met
pas c'est interdit dans les cantines de
fil en aiguille il a fallu à peu près 30
ans 30 ans de lobbying pour que à un
moment en 1974 un ministre de
l'Agriculture qui s'appelait Edgar
Pisani
un peu
face une sorte de d'erreur scientifique
en se disant bon allez c'est tellement
intéressant d'un point de vue
concurrentiel que on va l'autoriser
badaboum dans les années qui ont suivi
on a découvert que ce nitrite en
lui-même se nitrite de sodium ce poison
il n'était pas directement cancérogène
mais qu'il donne naissance à toute une
panoplie de composés cancérogènes qui
sont les mêmes que ceux que vous trouvez
dans le tabac
alors comment ils font pour être ce
nutrition il injecte il injecte comme ça
dans les dans les lardons dans des gros
seringues avec on a vu une vidéo je peux
avoir là je fais pas partie de
l'émission donc je regarde
voilà ah ouais donc là on voit les
piqûres dans l'avion c'est des c'est des
ce qu'on appelle des des machines
qu'on des trous tout au long et ça un
geste ça injecte de la nitrite ils
injecte du sel nitrité sodique alors le
sel nitrité sodique c'est c'est la loi
fait que c'est obligatoirement dans les
sacs jaunes c'est du nitrite de sodium à
0,6% donc c'est ultra dissout et l'idée
au début je vois Jean-Marie parce que je
l'ai je sais parce que
mon père mon père disait un jambon quand
tu as retirer l'os normalement il est
beaucoup moins lourd et ben la sortie il
est aussi tellement lui a injecté de
trucs que quand il avait l'os lui il
était scandalisé par ça et si personne
n'achète de la vie
et le truc c'est que ça le sel nitrité
sonique qu'on met dans les charcuteries
donc celle nitrité tout simplement c'est
du sel de cuisine de base avec ce petit
ce taux de nitrite et au début il se
disait les régulateurs les experts du
ministère de l'Agriculture on dit bon à
cette dose là il va pas y avoir de souci
sauf que aujourd'hui on s'est
parfaitement ça même été reconnu par
notre agence sanitaire l'Indes ça a été
reconnu par l'agence FSA l'agence
européenne ça a été reconnu la réalité
ce que je raconte dans le bouquin parce
que ça fait des années que je suis sur
le dossier en train de fouiller les
archives que j'ai fait les archives
américaines françaises allemandes belges
bref je c'est ma vie le finalement on a
compris avec un côté un certain retard
que ce sel nitrité sodique
il n'était pas immédiatement cancérogène
mais que il donnait naissance dans le
produit directement quand il réagissent
comme vous le disiez Fabrice tout à
l'heure comme vous le disiez Richard
mais tout le monde m'appelle Fabrice
[Rires]
comme tu disais tout à l'heure
en fait
c'est que le nitrite ou le nitrate il
réagit avec les composants de la matière
carnée et il donne naissance à des
composés nitrogés qui eux sont
cancérogènes alors on va on va on va
parler tout ça dans un sens il y a
beaucoup de choses à savoir donc en fait
on va découvrir vous allez voir on a
repris des images d'un cash
investigation pour bien comprendre
facilement tout ce sujet on découvre
notamment pourquoi et comment le jambon
devient aussi rose c'est vrai que le
jambon à la base c'est quelle couleur
c'est gris on l'appelle jambon blanc
exactement c'est vrai tu as raison
jambon blanc il devient rose alors
pourquoi c'est pour la vente c'est mieux
que c'est
pour l'aspect et si
tu veux d'acheter
du jambon sans nitrite 100 nitrite et
donc il se met sans conservateur une
couleur naturelle de viande de porc du
coup là-dedans
je t'ai apporté du de boudin blanc
ah non mais pas avec ça j'en ai je
connais parce que les fabricants ils
veulent pas que ça devienne rose si tu
rajoutes du nitrite dedans ça
deviendrait rose mais on est obligé donc
c'est pour ça ils font croire qu'on est
obligé de mettre du nitrite alors que et
j'ai pris quand même j'ai fait mon petit
shopping tout à l'heure la même marque
qui fait à la fois la version avec
nitrite la version sans nitrite et comme
ça surtout la même marque là elle fait
alors là ils font par exemple eux la
même marque qui fait du sans nitrite
pour un autre lui il est avec nitrite
avec une petite touche cuisinée par un
grand chef
c'est important aussi on y va avec le
nitrite et là ils sont encore plus
malins
[Rires]
dedans c'est culotté ils mettent ils
mettent une autre version je voudrais
qu'on remontre un jambon sans nitrite et
avec nitrite vous allez voir et juste du
côté des fabricants et des vendeurs et
ils disent que ils sont ils n'ont pas le
choix selon eux sans nitrite ils
arriveraient à me vendre plus rien ça
c'est avec il faut savoir ce que on
avait un extrait
les industriels ne peuvent pas s'en
passer un fabricant de charcuterie nous
explique pourquoi
c'est c'est vraiment pour la couleur
parce que vous dit le nombre de trois
prime parce que sinon on va le dire
qu'elle est pas fraîche faut qu'elle etc
donc en clair je cuis une viande ça
donne un jambon gris c'est quelque chose
va l'acheter et le marché ou une
consommateur n'est pas prêt à ça donc
pour vous aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un
problème de couleur en fait
oui clairement parce que sinon on peut
s'amener la viande avec du sel de
Guérande sans problème et ouais non mais
moi je suis un peu alors je peux
comprendre parce que c'est vrai que
quand on voit le jambon sans nitrite il
a une tetée il est chaud quand même faut
savoir ce qu'on veut si on veut
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que tu veux
donner à tes enfants juste avoir un truc
le plus beau possible est-ce que
vraiment les gros c'est le même le goût
c'est le même mais le coup il est le
même à fabriquer il est le même après la
date
le goût le goût il faut goûter il était
délicieux là j'ai apporté et ça encore
quand ça c'était le cash qu'on avait
fait avec Sandrine Rigaud il y a on
avait tourné en 2015 ça c'est 2016 à
l'époque par exemple c'était très
difficile de trouver en France du
jambon sec
sans nitrate sans nitrites fallait aller
chercher le jambon de Parme depuis le
cash depuis le premier bouquin que
j'avais fait sur la question depuis la
mobilisation de Yuka food watch la Ligue
contre le cancer Axel Kahn qui s'est
battu comme un chien pour faire
interdire ses additifs nitrés depuis il
y a quand même beaucoup d'industriels
français de toute taille qui recommence
à faire du très bon jambon sec sans
nitrite son nitrate sans nitrite
mais carrément il suffit il y en a même
chez les discorders il y en a même chez
voilà des des marques les moins chers
simplement le truc qui est injuste inné
à eux et je trouve pour moi qui moi me
révolte c'est que il faut que le
consommateur soit il est regardé
l'émission soit qu'il est nul bouquin
soit qu'il soit voilà superbe ces
questions pour être au courant et que le
c'est au gouvernement d'agir c'est au
gouvernement d'interdire les cancer qui
sont qui sont cons justement parce que
ils dorment regardez ce que ça peut
provoquer provoquer le nitrate
cette additif est au cœur d'un énorme
enjeu de santé publique le nitrite est
suspecté de jouer un rôle dans le
développement d'un cancer très fréquent
le cancer colorectal le troisième cancer
le plus mortel en France en cause un
phénomène qui arrive pendant la
digestion
vous avalez un morceau de charcuterie
vous pensez digérer tranquille ce que
vous ignorez c'est que les molécules de
nitrite vont réagir avec les protéines
de la viande
elles vont avoir tendance à se
transformer en substance très dangereuse
les nitrosamines
les quoi
on est juste sur les nitrosamines mais
il y a d'autres il y en a d'autres il y
en a toute une famille ni tropamine pour
que tu te rends compte c'est la même
chose qui a dans la fumée du tabac et
tsna les tobacs spécifiques nitrosamines
c'est ça qui rend la fumée du tabac
cancérogène tout simplement et les
nitrosamines donc elle elles vont se
former dans l'intestin ou lors de la
cuisson vous cuisez vous cuisez par
exemple je vous ai apporté des lardons
avec nitrites sans nitrites cela avec
cela par exemple quand vous cuisez des
lardons avec nitrite c'est ce que
rappelle les autorités de santé en
particulier le lève ça dans le dernier
rapport de de novembre dernier levain
c'est l'agence sanitaire européenne elle
rappelle que lorsqu'il y a cuisson de
lardons ni tracté ou ni traiter à la
poêle dans l'huile dans l'huile juste ou
de cuisson de cette de où vous avez fait
griller ou voilà
de dire c'est lardons ben cette huile en
fait par exemple des femmes enceintes
faudrait pas qu'elle le mange faut pas
s'en servir comme assaisonnement pareil
pour donc ça c'est un problème de
nitrosamine mais je souligne un truc
c'est que c'est pas juste le nitrogamine
parce que les nitrogamines c'est un des
problèmes mais il y a d'autres molécules
et je veux pas avoir la souder le public
avec des molécules des noms on est là
pas là pour faire un cours de chimie
mais là juste par exemple le dernier le
fer nitrozilé les nitrozottioles c'est
un cochon il y en a toute une famille
qu'il faut éviter regardez ils sont
allés interroger le patron d'un d'une
grande enseigne et vous allez voir à ses
yeux le nitrite au contraire et là pour
protéger les consommateurs
du jambon sans nitrite est-ce que c'est
possible c'est extrêmement dangereux je
le ferai jamais je ne prendrai jamais
cette façon aussi
jamais si je n'ai pas 100%
de certitude que je n'aurais pas de
botulisme maintenant il y a cette étude
qui nous dit qui peut avoir des
corrélations avec développement de
cancer là avec le botulisme c'est du sur
si vous voulez c'est pas une indigestion
comme ça c'est une maladie nerveuse
dégénérescence mortel ah oui c'est pour
protéger les consommateurs que vous
mettez des Nitris tout à fait d'accord
ce Président
c'est les mêmes qui fabriquent ces deux
gammes avec nitrite sans nitrites pour
arrêter aussi un moment parce que les
mecs ils y vont faut arrêter non plus de
les stigmatiser les mecs derrière c'est
des milliers d'emplois donc je vous dis
d'accord simplement ce qu'il faut
souligner c'est que à un moment il a été
auditionné par exemple par Richard Amos
et il a dit et c'est dans le verbe
intime ça du député c'est le député
pendant la mission parlementaire et lui
à la fin et c'est dans les actes de de
de la mission parlementaire il a dit ce
président de société qui quelques mois
après cette interview il a lancé du sans
nitrates sans nitrite et aujourd'hui
c'est plus de 40% de l'organe
très bien alors c'est bien mais en même
temps il continue à en faire du nitrité
et je finis juste un truc c'est que
il a dit à la fin de l'audition il a dit
ah il a dit au député il s'adressait
comme ça direct à lui il a dit Monsieur
le Député si demain vous êtes c’était
face caméra si demain vous interdisez le
nitrite moi je suis le roi du pétrole
parce que je sais faire alors pourquoi
ça fait déjà trois ans qu'ils ont dit ça
mais pourquoi alors il continue parce
que
avec les mêmes armes que les autres si
les autres tombent continuer en mettre
ils sont obligés d'en faire aussi c'est
le problème sinon on va dire sinon on va
dire cette marque là les saucisses elles
ont l'air dégueulasse les lardons ils
ont l'air dégueulasse on va prendre les
autres donc je peux comprendre c'est où
c'est les mêmes règles pour tout le
monde ou bien tu peux pas te dire moi je
vais faire que du sans nitrite je peux
dire qu'au risque de de de perdre
énormément de consommateurs on est
d'accord mais alors pourquoi pas tout
simplement l'interdire alors que
oui
le pauvre il veut se battre avec les
mêmes armes que les autres à un moment
si tu te bats pas avec les mêmes armes
que les autres tu peux pas parce que tu
vas voir tu vas avoir une marque qui va
arriver tu vas voir un jambon qui est
magnifique et de l'autre tu vas dire bah
tu te sens nitrite moi je vais dire
franchement les mecs même je me suis dit
même les gens même s'ils le et je pense
même les enfants c'est ça le problème
les enfants les ados moi bon voilà je te
le dis j'ai j'aurais beaucoup de mal à
manger celui que tu m'as montré avec la
petite Matthieu Delormeau
par exemple la grande enseigne dont tu
parles ce grand fabricant tout à fait
respectable comme tu dis il a
heureusement et moi je suis le premier à
les féliciter il y a quelques mois il a
décidé d'arrêter et de faire des croques
au nitrites il a dit bon moi je fais que
mes crocs il a dit moi je m'en fous en
fait les gamins ils sont pas en train
d'ouvrir
la couleur ou colorimètre pour avoir
s'il est bien rose non les gars les
gamins ils sont en train de bouffer le
transmission ils s'en foutent que ce
soir blanc et donc il a carrément banni
et je pensais
juste il faut que les consommateurs
soient informés des risques spécifiques
de cancer du côlon je rappelle juste un
chiffre c'est pas pour se mélangoisse
mais c'est quand même le corps du colon
en France c'est 43000 nouveaux cas c'est
le premier cancer chez les non-fumeurs
c'est 43000 nouveaux cas chaque année
juste pour la France 23 chez les mecs
20000 chez les femmes il y a en plus des
corrélations affirmées par l'unesc avec
cancer de la prostate chez les hommes
cancer des seins chez les femmes
d'autres maladies maintenant nouvelle
découverte de l'inseme le nitrite de
sodium il est corrélé aussi au diabète
de type 2
hypertension artérielle je veux dire
c'est un cauchemar alors autant poser
une question Guillaume à un moment
est-ce qu'on va pas trouver des produits
nocifs partout c'est à dire si on
commence à chercher un moment est-ce
qu'on va pas dire on peut plus rien
manger on peut plus rien voir et à un
moment de toute façon tout on dit
souvent dans l'alimentation c'est ce qui
fait la santé un moment tu dis bah tu
sais quoi je pourrais plus rien manger
je peux plus rien boire parce que de
toute façon dans tous les trucs il va y
avoir un rubrique qui va être conseiller
aux jeunes qui va être beaucoup aussi
je pense pas que ça parce que il y a une
question de coût aussi les consommateurs
à un moment moi je veux bien manger bio
manger sain etc mais ça c'est
extrêmement cher
par exemple entre 100 nitrite et un
moment c'est compliqué aussi tout à
l'heure je disais que même dans chez des
discounters soit des grandes marques
voilà pas cher on trouve maintenant tu
trouves du jambon de Bayonne impeccable
le truc c'est que les gens sont pas
informés là c'est la même marque sur le
même prix d'accord la même marque une
grande marque distributeur impeccable
jambon sec sans nitrate sans nitrite
super tu regardes les ingrédients jambon
de porc sel c'est ça les ingrédients ah
mais là par contre l'assiette de
charcuterie c'est la même on a on a mis
du gaffeur là pour cacher la marque mais
c'est le même produit je l'ai acheté
tout à l'heure
et là par exemple ah bon donc là il est
il est clean pas de nitrate pas de
nitrite bon le même avec là il est sans
avec nitrate dans l'assiette parce que
alors je sais pas peut-être que les gens
ils se disent ils vont pas aller voir
directement avec leur loupe
si il y a 2 millions de personnes qui
vont dire moi je bouffe plus de nitrates
j'espère je pense que c'est légitime tu
vois les femmes enceintes j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure on en a ici les enfants
c'est pour ça la mairie de Paris a
annoncé à confirmer que maintenant ils
vont interdire les additifs nitrés dans
la charcuterie très bien dans les écoles
dans le dans les dans les crèches mais
c'est on marche sur la tête de donner à
manger des aliments cancérogènes à des
femmes enceintes et je veux rebondir sur
un truc c'est si tu perds
[Rires]
que en fait par exemple tout était
cancérogène qu'on s'en sortait pas c'est
pas le cas je souligne juste que juste
après juste pendant ce qu'on avait
raconté dans le cash investigation
en 2015 le Centre international de
recherche sur le cancer le CRC c'est
l'agence cancer de l'OMS c'est les tops
c'est des c'est
mondiale sur le cancer a classé un
aliment un seul aliment en cancérogènes
certains il y en a pas d'autres les
charcuteries s'il y en a pas d'autres ça
veut dire que quand vous rentrez dans un
rayon dans un supermarché en général je
parle pas du rayon alcool mais on donne
pas de l'alcool au gamin d'accord on
donne pas de l'alcool aux femmes
enceintes il y a un petit pictogramme
interdit de boire femme enceinte on boit
pas
par contre il y a un seul rayon qui que
moi j'ai envie malheureusement d'appeler
réunion aliment cancérogènes de classe 1
selon l'OMS c'est le rayon charcuterie
et ça je trouve ça honteux qu'on soit en
train de créer en fait une sorte de
gamme de gamme sans nitrite pour les
personnes informées qui sont prêtes à
mettre quelques centimes de plus à la
tranche et puis les familles nombreuses
les agriculteurs qui sont les gros
consommateurs de charcuterie les
ouvriers le le les familles nombreuses
les gens qui sont oui qui je comprends
ont des enfants à nourrir ils poussent
samedi il se remplissent le caddie on
regarde le prix on regarde le prix dans
une période on va voir un peu les
réactions Béatrice
moi je pense que si on donne du sang
nitrite à des enfants ils vont
s'habituer ça va voilà il faut il faut
absolument informer les gens il faut que
le gouvernement interdise totalement
l'usage de nitrite comme ça il n'y aura
que du sang nitrite sur le marché et
voilà il y aura pas d'eau je comprends
pas qu'il est passé ce qui est
incroyable c'est que régulièrement le
soir ici on parle de ces sujets de
viande et que ce soit pour la santé avec
une viande propre mais bon pour la santé
cancérigène que ce soit une viande bonne
pour la santé mettre des gueux parce que
ce qui se passe dans dans des boucheries
c'est dégueu ou que ce soit de questions
éthiques avec les scandales de
maltraitance animale franchement juste
on commence à réfléchir faudrait qu'on
réfléchit juste à la consommation
globale de viande
bouché de père en fils et qui qui ont
besoin voilà ils ont besoin de
travailler et qui ont une traçabilité
la boucherie et tout c'est comme partout
il y a des brebis galeuses après la
plupart des bouchers je vous le dis font
très bien leur travail et on n'a pas
envie que déjà que les boulangers ils
sont en train de disparaître si on a
plus de boucher on a plus de boulanger
on a plus rien à un moment ça va être
compliqué moi je pense d'abord je pense
d'abord je pense d'abord au boucher aux
familles débouchés et à tous les gens
qui font travailler à tous et mine de
rien à toute l'industrie la boucherie
parce que je peux vous dire que si on
arrête la boucherie on va mettre
beaucoup de gens au chômage aussi pour
ça il faut toujours attention il
faut toujours équilibre les chéris ça
c'est comme écologie économique
Attention il faut toujours le bon
équilibre moi je pense d'abord à pas
mettre des gens au chômage et
aujourd'hui les gens ce qu'ils veulent
c'est pour voir vivre et pouvoir gagner
leur vie si on commence à tout arrêter
et attirer sur tout le monde et ben je
vais vous dire voilà on va se retrouver
avec plein de gens dans la rue et plein
de gens qui n'auront pas le disent du
mois pour manger c'est déjà il y en a de
plus en plus donc il y en a de plus en
plus qui font du sans nitrite plein de
bon j'ai pris bien sûr
Jean-Mi oui moi je suis comme Siri je
suis le visuel c'est très important
est-ce qu'on a pas encore trouvé le
moyen de le rendre rose sans utiliser
exactement ceci il y en a il y a des
techniques on va mettre des dragibus un
des techniques il y a de la plupart des
fabricants d'accord oui mais ça par
exemple si tu veux il est il a la même
couleur
là c'est avec sans nitrite là même
et la même chose sur le jambon donc il y
a tout absolument
pas problématiques parce qu'il donne pas
naissance à des composés
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire moi je
voulais lui poser une question elle est
intéressante j'en ne m'en suis pas sûr
mais je peux chanter
il y a une injustice au portefeuille il
faut qu'il soit honnête c'est que le
sang nitrite
mais on l'a déjà dit tout à l'heure le
son
de plus à la fabrication à la
fabrication et beaucoup plus après voilà
merci avec un truc en moins c'est plus
cher mais c'est vrai alors il y a
plusieurs raisons après il faut
reconnaître c'est plus je dis pas que
c'est il suffit pas si tu veux d'enlever
juste le nitrite c'est il faut il faut
être précautionneux au niveau de la
matière première et puis il y a une date
limite de consommation qui est plus
courte et donc ça fait que le
distributeur il est obligé d'avoir plus
de réactions
et c'est ça leur argument d'ailleurs les
armes nobistes en fait des industriels
qui ont du nitrite ils disent oui mais
regardez ça veut dire que après on va
pas pouvoir garder longtemps les
produits il va y avoir du gâchis non
mais attendez vous imaginez qu'on fasse
ça sur la salade en sachet qu'on se dit
bon allez on va mettre un plateau de
nitrite dessus comme ça on l'a
conservera pendant des semaines mais
c'est du délai horrible
on sait combien ça fait de morts par an
le nitrite réellement alors il y a du
tout il y a une évaluation qui a été
différente Axel Kahn lui disait plus de
4000 Axel cas le président de la Ligue
contre le cancer il avait dit plus de
4000 personnes mortes par en France tous
les ans devant la mission parlementaire
avec avec Ramos choquant on a eu la
scène en direct où il y avait le chef du
lobby Ramos voilà attiré les vers du nez
en lui disant mais allez vous allez dire
le chiffre dites le chiffre dites le
chiffre finalement il a lâché 1200 quand
même là les députés se sont regardés en
disant attendez on a bien entendu 1200
personnes mortes par an et là le chef du
lobby a dit oui mais c'est chez les gros
mangeurs mais la question c'est
justement
Guillaume dernière question il paraît
que quand les industriels retirent des
nitrites qui sont obligés de rajouter
plein de sel est-ce que c'est vrai pour
la santé franchement Guillaume Le j'ai
amené là un échantillonnage dont on
aurait pu prendre un stock aller
directement en magasin vous allez voir
qu'il y a du sang nitrite moins 20 % de
moins 25 % de sel donc cet argument
aussi il est fictif le jambon de Parme
ça fait des années il y a moins de sel
que dans plein de jambon sec qui sont
nitrités quoi en fait il y a on se moque
c'est il y a du poker menteur dans cette
histoire qui révoltante dernière
question qu'est-ce qui se passe en fait
vous dites qu'il y a les mêmes
composants ou que ça réagit de la même
manière dans notre corps que la
cigarette et pourtant sur la cigarette
il y a marqué nuit gravement à la santé
donc en fait sur le nitrite il devrait
aussi marquer à côté
les autorités sanitaires devraient
éduquer les gens parce que même moi qui
suis à fond sur l'alimentation
concrètement le nitrite je savais pas ce
que c'était il y a un autre député la
semaine dernière et ou alors il faut
marquer dessus il y a un autre député
Loïc Prudhomme la semaine dernière qui a
proposé une nouvelle proposition de loi
exactement
qui a dit
[Rires]
[Musique]
ils sont plus habitués
je parle de de du visuel qu'ils ont mis
sur la couche sur la couverture en fait
en disant ils vont chanter la
charcuterie la semaine prochaine
avec nitrite et sans nitrite ça change
de nutriscore hélas
c'est pas le nutri-score ne tient pas
compte des additifs c'est un vrai c'est
une vraie
dans la charcuterie le scandale va vous
appeler hein cette semaine merci
Guillaume c'était très fort merci et
vraiment bravo on revient quand tu veux